[Music]
a new Chinese app recently hit the top
of Us app charts real short I just
looked it's like number 18 Entertainment
app something like that wow what's the
first 17 what the [__] is it uh like
[__] Netflix and all the big
ones what the [__] is it the app offers
bite-sized English scripted video
content like quibby but with a catch
instead of Hollywood hitters its cheesy
degrade soap operas meets Hallmark films
the shows are about Affairs scandals
meritable Intrigue and absurd plots here
are a few titles son-in-law's Revenge we
know what that probably
is yeah I'm getting married without you
okay never divorce a secret billionaire
ays I repeat never divorce a secret
billionaire
ays during the p pmic micro series took
off in China amongst Blue Collar
demographics as a substitute for movie
theaters a show is typically shot as 50
plus episodes 50 plus episodes that are
90 to 120 seconds each real short
adapted a lot of these Chinese romance
dramas for Western audiences it's free
to watch but you view ads to unlock more
episodes or pay for coins to unlock them
Tech crunch estimates the app has been
downloaded 11 million times across IOS
and Android and has generated $22
million in net revenue to date since
it's August 22 launch it's kind of like
[__] uh it's kind of like Darman I
was going to say this is Darman M it is
but it's like it's like dirtier yeah so
it's fanfiction yes it's basically like
wad stories yeah visualized yes below
are the first two episodes of wild show
called the double life of my billionaire
husband yeah sure let's watch
one you ready I'm ready I mean borrow
$50,000 mom needs Kenny dialysis and
really don't have have any money Natalie
the the thing is how Shameless of you to
come here and beg us for money I'll pay
you guys back I promise this was shot on
a Canon
7D this is shot on a Canon 5D Mark II
that's what I mean dude this looks like
[__] 2010 this is crazy man this is
this is
crazy Lauren maybe we can let her borrow
the money I mean it's her mother that's
sick you're still thinking about your
ex-wife no no do I need to remind you
this is your family now this would have
been a college humor sketch yeah
now
George without me you'd have nothing
a it isn't my loser sister asking for
money like a beggar how
pathetic this is a mistake
wait we'll give you the money what
if you marry Sebastian Klein in my
place
my daughter is so smart that's a good
idea you know why this works what the
[__] wait what you know why this
works cuz this has the same amount of
plot twist as
anime yeah maybe that's what people
don't realize this is Anime this is
Anime for Americans yeah I don't
watching [__] do stupid cartoons okay
yeah but I will watch some real yeah
yeah watch some real [__] you know see
who's going to marry Sebastian Klein guy
sounds like a real piece of work yeah
real funny to think about some blue
collar construction guy watching this
being like I mean you know it's like
it's what you know like the chicks are
hot yeah yeah the chicks are super hot
that's why I like it it's kind of good
you can just kind of turn your brain off
and kind of just get absorbed in it you
know this like hot chicks in it so yeah
yeah yeah I don't really like it for the
plot or anything but no Sebastian Klein
is a [__] dick though I don't know
like I wouldn't want to marry
him Sebastian Klein the legitimate son
of the Klein family the IL legitimate
the son of the Klein family who's the
Klein family who's the Klein
Family the son of Ethan Klein Ethan
Klein isn't he in jail right now yep
he's a dirt bag and a good for nothing
loser well then why do you have to marry
him so she can get the money that's why
I can't marry him that's right Natalie
is also your daughter she can be the one
who marries sebaster de Klein no I'm not
o
do you want us to pay for your mother's
medical bills do you want us to pay for
your or
not wait they're sisters though aren't
they sisters yeah shouldn't they have
the same mom maybe they're half sisters
half sciss
okay fine I know I'm sorry I'm just
[__] come on I'll marry Sebastian
Klein these shows are too smart for
me K get up
it's time to
go hurry the [__] up Klein I said move
it he's probably going to be hot as [__]
I'm guessing
right jeez officer what is the rush
most nah in in Ohio
8 people want to get out of here
faster
[Music]
don't drive recklessly again next time
it won't be just 3
days I can't make any promises
officer he ate on that
damn no because he ate him up officer
all right well then you're staying in
jail he Sebastian CLE you can't do that
again Sebastian clears this cop yeah
yeah cleared
him
this [__] fake ass Inception music or
uh succession
music what if what if Brian Cox just
appeared in the middle of this Sebastian
get in the car you [__] you [__] with
yeah you're embarrassing me oh [__]
that's the father of the CL [__] dude
okay I'm in yeah would be just an
amazing actor amidst all of them yeah
you're going to marry that piece of [__]
woman so help me God and I don't care if
she's a
loser I need their
[Music]
money man this would have been a music
video in
[Music]
2011 Daniel everything going according
to plan yes boss you being in Jail's a
perfect
Alibi I'm kind of picturing someone in
an apartment like on their deck watching
them film this they're like oh it's like
a vlog or something yeah someone's down
there filming a vlog I guess yep oh and
what about the Quinn family any issues
there no the Quinns have agreed to marry
their daughter to you oh
interesting they kept their end of the
bargain they keep their end of the barg
and then that's when we move
in you got it boss yeah dude yeah this
is it
there's no point in trying anymore it is
it's so similar to Darman I didn't even
realize that yeah it's Darman model why
does that work that
style I think well obviously one social
media it's like easy to it's like a
simple storyline to follow through um I
actually think when things are like shot
cinematic or like really artistic I
actually think most people don't like
that yep really yeah I I think most
people give a [__] people would rather
that straightforward clear it make it
just gets to the point like yeah I think
a regular person when they see when
they're consuming like a film or
something they don't necessarily want
art yeah they don't want a crazy 22 like
establishing shot of a location just
like all right who's the characters like
who hates each other yeah you know
that's why anime is superior
mhm